لقد كنت هناك كنت مع والدك
عندما تم القبض عليه منذ أكثر من
عام ما حدث أولاً وقبل كل شيء أريد أن
أقول إنه من دواعي سروري أن ألتقي بك وأنا ممتن حقًا
لمنحك
فرصة التحدث وأنت تعلم أنني أتمنى
كان هذا في ظل ظروف أفضل
بالطبع كان ما حدث يومًا ما
كان والدي جالسًا في
مكتبه ويتحدث عندما سمعنا فجأة
طرقًا على الباب وفتحنا الباب
وكانت مجموعة من ستة إلى سبعة
ضباط شرطة على الأقل يرتدون ملابس
كمدنيين ، أمسكوا والدي
بقوة شديدة وأخذوه إلى
الجانب في ذلك الوقت ووعدوا
أنهم يريدون فقط التحدث إليك ،
لذلك قالوا إنه سيعود
بحلول وقت الغداء جاهزًا
، سيكون  كن مستعدًا للعودة إلى المنزل
وهي بضع ساعات ، كما نعلم جميعًا ،
كانت هذه كذبة لأنه بعد مرور عام
ونصف وما زال هناك
لأكون صادقًا ، فإن هذا الوضع برمته لوجود
والدي في السجن لا معنى له
انا انا  هذا الرجل الذي نتحدث عنه هو
رجل هو واحد من أكثر
المواطنين الذين يلتزمون بالقانون الذين لم تقابلهم على الإطلاق ، لم
يحصل أبدًا على تذكرة وقوف السيارات في
حياته من أجل الله ، فقد كرس
حياته كلها لتحسين حياة الناس
حياة الناس من حوله أفضل
آسف وقد قام أيضًا بالكثير من
الخدمات العامة للبلد ، وهذا أمر
محير للغاية ولماذا يستهدفون
شخصًا قضى حياته كلها في
محاولة لمساعدة البلد الذي
يعاقبه الآن